انت ما تبغى تكون في هذا الموضع ليش تحط
نفسك موضع شيء انت بالنسبه له نمله
واهدافكم متعارضه انك عشان بس بيبيلك
اهدافي هذه النقطه يعني هل هو يقدر الحالي
يفكر الحاله بدوني لاني بضغط انتر يعني
بدون ما انتر هو مبدع شيء قلل عدد وفيات
البشريه
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابو مالح في هذه الحلقه
يؤكد ضيفي تاكيدا لا يدع مجانا للشك ان
الاله ستتفوق على الانسان تستهزم البشريه
وانها مهدد حقيقي للوجود البشري ويتفق على
هذا الطرح طبعا علماء وباحثين كثر حبيت
نتكلم عن الذكاء الاصطناعي بشكل موسع
والصراحه اني اطمح الى تكثيف الطرح في هذا
المجال من زوايا متعدده لعل المعرفه هذه
تساعدنا في فهم المستقبل ومن يدري ممكن
احد يقدر يعدل في مسار هلاكنا ضيفي في هذه
الحلقه الدكتور ابراهيم مسلم هو استاذ في
الذكاء الاصطناعي من جامعه اوكسفورد وهو
من المطالبين بحوكمه الذكاء الاصطنا
السيطره عليه
فوجد جهود اللي تقوم فيها الحكومات اليوم
بالسيطره عليه وين وصلنا هل مثلا نتعامل
معه مثل تعاملنا مع المفاعلات والقنابل
النوويه
وحقيقه في اسئله كثيره في محاوله لفهم
ذكاء الاله ومستقبلها حيث ان الاذكى يسيطر
على الاخر قطعا يقول ابو احمد ان الاله
اذكى لا محاله
قبل ان نبدا اذا كنت مهتم بسماع حلقات
فنجان اول ما تنزل ما ودك يفوتك شيء منها
تابع فنجان وفعل اشعاراته في منصات
البودكاست وراح احط رابط
الرابط في وصف الحلقه مع العلم ان موعد
نسر الحلقه الصوتيه وساعه سته صباحا كل
يوم احد والمرئيه الساعه سته مساء كل يوم
اربعاء ثلاث ايام من نشر الصوتيه الان
لنبدا المتشائمين والمتشائرين
انا من اتذكرك الحلقه
ماني متشائم في فرق بين اني لما اقول لك
هل تتوقع لو اسالك مثلا هل ممكن تموت من
هذه السياره لا قدر الله ممكن ممكن هل
امشي واقول عبد الرحمن اتوقع انه بيموت
محادث السياره متشائم في فرق ملقوق شيء
ممكن وخلينا اربط حزام حط الحساباتك بين
اني اقول هذا توقعي انا ماني متشائم انا
اقول اذا الوضع استمر على ما هو عليه
فانا متشائم بس انا متفائل ان الوضع ما
راح يستمر
طيب بس قبل شي احنا
نتناقش يعني
على الذكاء الاصطناعي فاحس اني اغلب الناس
يشوفوني ذكرت
فيلم الناس تقول انه خطر الذكاء الصناعي
فيما بعد ما ادري كيف وزي كذا يربط على وش
جالس يشوف اليوم من ذكر الصناعي بس
وهو شف انت تتكلم
اصطناعي اللي هو ضعيف والقوي والخارق
لما نتكلم عن يعني ذكاء الاصطناعي اللي
ممكن يتفوق على ذكاء بشر يعني هذا عرقتهم
يصنف خطر وجودي يعني وهذا ممكن
ما في لو تشوف تاريخ التقنيه ماشي بنفس في
رتم متصاعد يعني ما في شيء يمنع يعني ما
في شيء تقدر
تثبت انك ما تقدر تخطى مثلا ذكاء الانسان
يعني مثلا ما في اتجاه واحد فيزيائي جالس
يحاول يبني مركبه تمشي اسرع مسرعه الضوء
انسى الموضوع ما اقدر انزل مثلا تحت الصفر
كلبا في شيء اشياء مستحيل فيزيائيه
فيزيائيه ما يحاولوا حلو
هل
لو نرتب ذكاءات الكائنات مثلا من مدري أمي
بحشرات حيوانات انسان هل حنا الحد الاقصى
ما في شيء ولا لا فالناس ماشيين على اساس
انه ممكن
ذكاء الصناعي خلني اعرف اوكي متى يصير
الانسان ذكي شوف اول شيء انه نسبي يعني ما
بدك تقول على شيء ذكي او غبي الا لما تعرف
الهدف بمعنى اتخيل انك مثلا مطالع شفتني
كذا قاعد اكسر سيارتي مثلا
ادور مفتاح ولا بتقول اوكي
من الحكم بقصه نوح مثلا انه كيف صحراء
وعرفت علي بس لما تعرف الهدف
قصه موسى مع الخضر لما عرف السياق بانوا
تصرف ذكي فاحيانا في تصرف قريب ذكي لما
تعرف الهدف يطلع غريب والعكس التصرف قديم
يعني توك كنت العب مع زين
تخيل انك جيت كذا لقيتني قاعد حلو هناك
لعبه غبيه
الحركه هذه غبيه قياسا على هدفها تقول
تصرف ذكي ولا غبي هو نسبه الاهداف عاده
بس الاهداف هنا مشكله ترى ما في شيء اسمه
هدف ذكي وهدف غبي الهدف هدف يعني زي
المسلمات رياضيات يعني سيف رياضيات الحين
انا اقدر مثلا ابدالك من نظريه وابدا
استنتج لك مثلا الف اذا ب اذا جيم جيم دال
المسلمات فهمتوا عليه تسال رياضي يقول لك
والله سلامات احنا بادين فيها هي سلامات
عرفت علي زي مثلا خطين متوازيين تقطعون
اقصر مسافه بين
خط مستقيم
فالمسلمات هذه خلاص انت اهم شيء انه يكون
انك ما يكون عندك تعارض في شروط على
المسلمات بس
نفس الكلام الاهداف ما تجي تقول على في
نقطه معينه انت تقول له هدف هدف يعني نرجع
لو سالتني مثلا قلت ابراهيم مثلا ليش تبغى
تنزل اقول مثلا ابي ولدي يتعلم
اقول لك
ابغى ينجح في حياتك
عرفت علي يعني في حد بقول لك
ممكن تتغير يعني ممكن مثلا لو جاء ولدي
قال يبغى انا ما اعرف شطرنج الامور هذه
انا لقيت نفسي اكثر مثلا في الرياض ولا
كذا
اوكي كان ودي يعني اذا بس الله يوفقك
يلا كم تبي تحرق فلوسك
اذا كان هذا بيتغير فهمهرف وسيله
بس ما في شيء في الدنيا مثلا يخليني اخذ
حبه مثلا تخليني اكره يعني
ولا تشيل همهم وحتى لو ذبحتهم قالوا
يحاسبك
اغير هدف النهايه بالعكس بتجبرني يمكن
اعاركك
يعني التصرفات تقدر تقيسها على الاهداف
والاهداف في اشياء بسيطه وفي اهداف نهائيه
اهداف نهائيه ما تتغير
والاهداف ولا تقدر بعد هذه فيها
يعني في المجال
يسمونها في نظريه اسمها رقتهم
او نظريه التعامد تقول لك انه ما تقدر
تستنتج الاهداف من ذكاء يعني ممكن تكون
مره ذكي
وعندك هدف سخيف ولا تكون عندك اهداف معقده
وتكون ذكائك متوسط فما في علاقه بين
الهداف والذكاء عرفت علي يعني ما تقدر
تستنتج
الهدف من الذكاء ولا الذكاء من الهدف
يعني تخيل اقول لك مثلا
وشلون سيارتي اذا كان اليوم الاحد
بالضبط هذا التعامل في الرياضيات يعني ما
الذكاء ما يعلمك اي شيء على الاهداف
والاهداف ما يعلمك
بس متى نقول بس
نقول على على
هدف ذكي ولا متى يصير شيء ذكي متى الانسان
ذكي عشان اذا عرفت ان هذا الشيء ذكي باله
تحقيق الاهداف هل هو وشو بالضبط اللي يخلي
هذا الشيء ذكي عشان اعرف كيف خليت ذكاء
اصطناعي شوف
زي ما قلت لك ما تقدر تقول على شيء ذكيه
الان كيف تعرف ان الشيء هذا
اوكي هذا يعني
اللي يواجهوه العلماء قبل زين وكان في
تعريف كثيره والفلاسفه على قوتهم كل واحد
عنده نظرته بعدين جاء انا حلو اللي هو
عرقتهم مؤسسه المحاسب هذا اينشتاين حقنا
وكاشف يعني اوكي صح يمكن لو اسهل مئه واحد
عن تعريف الذكاء
التعريف بس مئه واحد هل الانسان ذكي كان
في اجماع انه انسان ذكي
فقال اوكي ليش ما نحول التعريف الى اختبار
جميل وبدل ما احاول اعرف الذكاء الاصطناعي
خلني احاول اتعرف عليه
عن طريق الاختبار هذا فالاختبار بسيط انه
انا بحاور اله او بحاور شيء انا ولا انسان
حلو لا اذا ما قدرت اميز
هل انا اتحاور مع اله او انسان او ما قدرت
افرق فانا اذا ما قدرت تفرق
حلو
فهذا تقدر تقول يعني
طريقه تقعد تقيس فيها ذكاء
بس انت اخذت الانسان هو كان معيار
وهذه يسمونها المدرسه السلوكيه في الذكاء
الاصطناعي اللي هي يعني تعريف الذكاء هو
يعني
سلوك معين اذا انت عندك السلوك هذي خلاص
معناته انت
جاء فيلسوف ثاني اسمه
جون سيل حلو قال اعتذر نظره وقال شوف وطرح
حجه اسمه حجه الغرفه الصينيه
قال تخيل في واحد في غرفه زي اللي احنا
فيها الحين وفيها كل الكتب اللي يحتاجها
والتعليمات اللي يحتاجها عشان يترجم اي
جمله من انجليزي الى اللغه الصينيه
الغرفه هذه تدخل عليه بس انت ورقه مكتوب
فيها جمل باللغه الانجليزيه هو يتبع
التعليمات ويطلعها الثانيه مترجم
اللغه الصينيه
اللي هو تشبيه للحاسب الحاسبه يتبع
التعليمات
فتعريف سير للذكاء انه لا هو مو مجموعه
تصرفات هو يعني هو كيفيه فقط ظاهره يعني
كيف تفكر
له علاقه طيب في ناس ردوا عليك
ما في منطقه معينه تعرف الصينيه ولا تعرف
الانجليزيه
فالغرفه كامله تعرف الصيني
المقياس الانسان في ناس يقول لا
ممكن يقول اشياء
يعني غبيه في ناس فقال
فيه اللي يتصرف بعقلانيه
او اللي مثلا يفكر بعقليه
يعني سلوكيه وتفكير معيار انسان معيار
المنطقه
واليوم يوم سوي الذكاء الاصطناعي
من مدى تشابه مع الذكاء الانسان يعني هل
هو او وين قصور حتى مقابل ذكاء الانسان
اللي اليوم احنا وصلنا
بالضبط زي
شبهها
يعني تصميم الطياره وكيف الاصفر يطير يعني
في الفكره العامه بس خلاص تطور بمسار
مختلف تماما فعندنا في الاله هذا التشابه
فمحاولوا انه عندنا خلايا عصبيه الانسان
وشيء ثاني
يشابهون عشان يوصل الى الذكاء الاصطناعي
اليوم حاولوا ايش الخوارزميات التطوريه
مثلا يعني على مستوى المخبز على مستوى
البيولوجيا
قالوا اوكي الان التطور في استبعاد وفيه
طفره جينيه وفي تزاوج
الجيل يكون اكثر كفاءه
فكرتها انك تبدا بحلول عشوائيه ونفس
التطور اللي
البقاء الاقوى يعني ممكن هذا في البدايه
الحلو عشوائيه كلها يعني تجيب لك نتائج
سيئه بس هذا نتيجه افضل من هذا بشوي وهذا
نتيجه افضل من هذا بشوي
فاحتمال ان هذول ينجون الجيل اللي بعده
اعلى وبعدين الحلين
وتستمر زين وتسوي طفرات جينيه بعد عشوائيه
مع الوقت
الين ما تلقى التسلسل هذا جيل عن جيل
معدل
الدقه يزيد
في لغز سمونه
احط ثمان وزراء بحيث ما حد يهجم الثاني
فتجد تحلها بخزنه الطوريه تجي تقول في
البدايه حطهم اماكن عشوائيه حلو
وبعدين تشوف مين اللي فيهم اقل تعارض يعني
مثلا فيها في الترتيب هذا حصل انه في مثلا
عشره
والترتيب هذا فيه ثمانيه فهنا الثمانيه
مثلا قدرته النجاح اعلى وبعدين الجيل
الثاني تاخذ اللي ثمانيه واللي سبعه
وبعدين تقسم
الرقعه نصفين وتدمج الحلين
وتستمر وبعدين تسوي طفره عشوائيه تحركه
زيرو عشوائي تعرفت عليه
هذا برضو بطريقه ثانيه استحاء من الطبيعه
طيب
متى متى
اول مره
كذا وقفت وقالها لكم
الذكاء الاصطناعي اللي اليوم
والله صراحه اي نسخه اربعه اربعه صراحه
يعني
مخيف صراحه يعني
انا ما
قلت ما كنت اتوقع يوصل الذكاء الاصطناعي
يوم من الايام هذا مستوى
بس ان اليوم اجلس معك
في 20 23 وهذا ذكاء اصطناعي موجود
اتوقع بنوصل هذا يمكن عشرين ثلاثين زي كذا
كنا ماشيين في قفزه
تصير شوف لانه يا اخي اللغه ترى من اصعب
التحديات اذا كان اصنعه لانه
شوف
حتى لاحظ اللغه اسمها بشريه من كل
الحيوانات موجوده
يعني كل الحيوانات مثلا في عندي ابصار
تشوف وتسمع يعني
بس سمعت اللغه والتواصل وانه في فكره
براسي اوصلها لراسك عن طريق اللغه
ما هي موجوده في الحيوانات يعني او علقت
بهالمستوى
بعد فيها تحدي يعني خاص لانه على عكس مثلا
الصور والصور
[موسيقى]
البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه الخدمات
مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
صوره
او صوت عباره مجموعه ارقام يعني اعطيك
مجموعه بيكسلز وكل بيكسل مرقه من صفر الى
100 وصفر اسود ومئه وابيض اذا افترضنا
الصوره
ونفس الكلام الصوت الصوت يعني هي
الوقت في
علو الصوت
فالارقام سهل التعامل معها فمثلا في الصور
تقدر بطريقه سهله مثلا افصل لك صور النهار
عن الليل عرفت عليه من بيانات اللي فيها
اقدر مثلا
حتى طرق قديمه يعني في الصوت اقدر افصل لك
مثلا احلل الصوت الى ترددات وعاده ان
الرجال تردد اقل من تردد صوت المراه فاقدر
افصلك صوت الذكور علينا
لانه موجوده على صيغه ارقام سهله
الهضم بالنسبه للكمبيوتر شوي ولو انه يعني
مو بسهوله
اللغه مشكلتها انه
حروف كتابه يعني ما تقدر تعطيك كلمه مثلا
طبيب
وبطاريه ومستشفى زين
طبيب وبطاريه فيها احرف متشابه اكثر من
كده
يمكن كلمه طبيب اقرب لي مستشفى بالمعنى
فهي رمزيه ما هي الارقام فانت او هذه اول
مشكله انت كيف احول هذه المجموعه
الرموز هذه الى ارقام يقدر يتعامل مع
حالها جميل
فهذا اول تحدي
وكيف حلو التحدي هذا ندخل شوي فيها حقتهم
[موسيقى]
حاول يحولون كل كلمه الى يعني ارقام زي
كانك تقدر تخيلها كانها المثال المضربه
يعني
تفاح ولا برتقال ولا قهوه
حق التفاح وتغير خط واحد يمكن فجاه يطلع
القهوه ولا تغير حق خط واحد يطلع لك لبن
ولا ما له علاقه ببعض اوكي
الفكره كيف اني اقدر اسوي مثلا
باركود بحيث مثلا لو اغير خط في التفاح
الاحمر طلع لي التفاح اخضر شيء قريب
اثنين من البعض مثلا تفاحه احمر تفاحة عنب
احمر مدري البرتقالي حلو قسمه اثنين اثنين
وتقول اوكي هذا خط هذا خطين
وبعدين تعمل كل مجموعه كانها يعني يعني
شيء واحد حلو اوكي وش اقرب مثلا التفاح
التفاحتين والبرتقالتين اقرب لبعض من مثلا
القهوه الشاهي تقول تزيد خطينا تزيد خط
هنا فلما تنتهي تصير عندك انا زي شجره
تقريبا يعني
مو هذا بالضبط اللي يصير بس هي نفس الفكره
اني كيف احول
اعطي كل كلمه باركود بحيث اني لو اغير رقم
او اغير شيء بسيط على الاقل يطلع لي كلمه
قريبه بالمعنى
كيف سووها في اللغه مقياس التشابه خلوه
مقياس السياق يعني مثلا ليش مثلا كلمه
الاحد تشبه يوم الاثنين
لاني لما اقوم مثلا قابلت عبد الرحمن يوم
تتوقع لاحد يعني احصائيا احتمال ظهور
الكلمات هذه بعد قابلت فلان يوم
اعلى من مثلا
كرسي كاميرا صح المنطقيا نشوفها في يعني
في لوحه المفاتيح في الجوال مثل ما انا
اكتب صح ايه بالضبط هو ياخذ السياق يمكن
يكتب السلام
فهذه اللي استخدموها عشان الكلمات جنب بعض
ويطلعون باركود لكل كلمه بس ان الاله اللي
ترتبه ولا لا
الاله هي اللي تحاول تستكشف المهم ما في
احد راح كتب السلام وقال لهم انه بعدها
الاحتمال بيكون عليكم هو الاله الحاله
اكتشفت انه عليكم
تجمع كل البيانات وتسحب الانترنت عشان
تطلع بالحصائيات هذه يقول عندك يلا هذا
البيانات شوف وش اكثر احتمال بعد كلمه
السلام حلوه اكثر كلمه بعد مثلا
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
فمنها يحاول
يستخرج باركود لكل كلمه بحيث
اذا كانوا
هم احصائيا
والاشياء اللي لاحظوها بعدين مثلا لما
انتهى الذكاء الاصطناعي من التدريب لو
تجيب مثلا الباركود حق كلمه مثلا ملك
بعدين تطرح منها كلمه ذكر
فانت تجمع كلمه انثى
تطلع لك الباركود حقت ملك
قلت
جيب الباركود حق كلمه ملك حلو اوكي بعدين
اطرح منها لانها الحين خلاص هي الفكره
كلها اني انا بحول هالرموز وهالخطوط الى
ارقام عشان يقدر يهضم الكمبيوتر
فالباركود حق ملك اطرح منه الباركود حق
كلمه ذكر حلو اجمع عليه الباركود حق كلمه
انثى
فهذا اول مشكله على الاقل انحلت انه قدرنا
نحول هالرموز
[موسيقى]
بس هل يشتغلوا عليها يعني بتخيل انهم
يسوونها بالانجليزي
[موسيقى]
فهل اشتغلوا عليها انهم
يسوونها بالعربي ولا هي الاعلى صارت تفكر
وتشوف اللغات الثانيه وتبدا تسوي الباركود
وتبدا تحطوا العمليات الحسابيه لحالها ما
تفرق حتى لغه برمجه يعني واخواتها
تعطيه بس كميه لصوص ما في
مختلف يختلف يعني تماما يعني فهمت علي ان
التراكيب اللغويه بين اللغات لحالها تختلف
يعني مين اللي يفكر هل الاله صارت تفكر
حاله
انت اعطيت الاله هدف
مكتشف الطريق من نفسها
ابغاك تتنبا بالكلمه هذه اذا كان هذه
الكلمات هي اللي سبقتها حلو ولا لا
برنامج مره جيد في التنبؤ بالنصوص زين
معناته ما قدرت
تنبا زي مثلا بيتعلموا ولدك مثلا خلاص ما
انت تختبرها خلاص شيل عن الجوال وتشيل عنا
مثلا
انترنت
وتوديه مدرسه مثلا ما
هي متساهله
مالك طريقه انك تجيب درجات الا انك فعلا
تتعلم
هذا التاسك قال اوكي انت الحين عندك
الكلمات هذه يلا تنبا هذه فما قدر انه
يفهم
يقدر يفهم حتى تعطيه اي لغه الحين
اذكر قبل سنه طلع خبر هذا اللي في جوجل
قال انه
الاله اصبحت واعيه او شيء الاستقاله علشان
قبل سنه الكلام هذا وانا كنت اقولها يعني
كاني يعني
متى ما صارت الاله تفهم جمله
نقعد تعبنا واحنا قاعدين نمشي لك ساعه
اقول انا زين
التعقيدات في اللغه هذه والسياق المحلي
يعني انا على بالي اعطيت الجوله بعد خمس
سنوات
اعطيتها
وفهمها قلت له ترجمها
تخيل جمله هذه
استوعب
فهذا التعقيد ثاني في اللغه حتى اللغه بعد
ترى متعقدات اللغه انه مين مجرد ترى
مجموعه كلمات لو مثلا مترجم اللغه اللغه
يقابلها كلمه ويمكن بس اختلاف في الترتيب
شوي ومكتوبه بطريقه مختلفه لا في افكار في
لغه ما هي موجوده في لغه ثانيه يعني مثلا
في بعض اللغات تقدر تتكلم بدون سياق زمني
حلو يعني
لازم تحدد هل انت الماضي والمضارع ولا
المستقبل في اللغه الصينيه لا تقدر تكون
يعني مبهم شوي عرفت عليه في بعض اللغات ما
فيها كلمات
يمين يسار قدام ورا في بيتكلمون دائما
شمال جنوب شرق غرب عرفت مثلا اقول لك هذه
يدي الشمال وهذه يد الجنوب ولو روح كذا
يدي الشرق
ففي اشياء في اللغه
احيانا ما هي موجوده في لغات اخرى
يعني هذا اول تحدي اول شيء فيه سياق وفي
معاني وفيها
وثالث شيء اللي هو
مقطع صوتي في النهايه مقطع محدد
الجمله ممكن تكون 20 كلمه واخر كلمه لها
علاقه
مثلا قاعد مثلا اسولف مع واحد اقول له
والله ثمانيه وقابلت عبد الرحمن
وجابري والله ترك الله يعطيه العافيه مويه
وسوينا الحلقه واستمتعنا وبعدين وانا طالع
قلت مثلا
تشرب من ماء الكوثر ان شاء الله
انا قلت مين
مين اللي جاب
تركي تركي لاني
مثال صعب شوي بس
يعني في المثال هذا
انا قلت
الكوثر لانه
جميل
فلاحظ كلمه مرتبطه باول الجمله حتى يمكن
حتى واضحه
فهذا الترابط صعب شوي فاول شيء سواه قالوا
خلنا مثلا يصير في تغذيه عكسيه يعني
الشبكه العصبيه بدل ما اعطيها
هالباركود حلو لا اعطيه الباركود والمخرج
اعطيه كمدخل
للباركود الثاني اللي هي الكلمه اللي
بعدها بحيث يصير في سياق وش الكلمه اللي
اجت قبلي
كشفوا ان هذا ما نجح على مدى جمله طويله
وكذا فيها صعوبات في التمرين وكذا جاء
بعدين فيه نموذج ثاني يسموها
او الذاكره الطويله قال لا في نسوي شيء
بحيث انه
يحدد وش الاشياء اللي يتذكرها وايش
الاشياء اللي ينساها بسرعه
اعطت قفزه شوي بس ما حلت المساله اللي حل
المساله يبدو الحين اللي هو هذا نموذج
والمحولات اللي طلع من جوجل 2017 اللي
ركز على فكره
والتركيز قال لا
في الجمله في كلمات ازيد عليها تركيز
واقلل عليها التركيز
هذا اول حنقول سهام بس اكبر اسهام في
صراحه انه صار قابل انك
تجزع المساله وتوزعها على
الكمبيوتر اول النماذج هذه صعبه لانها
تسلسليه
يعني ما اقدر مثلا
نقول اطبخ كيكه في قسمين كل واحد فرن
الكيكه تاخذ سعر الفرن قسمتها نصين تاخذ
ساعه ساعه
لا سمح انك توزع تمرن بالتوازي
وعلى بيانات هائله فصار سرعه التجربه اعلى
بكثير
فهذا يمكن
تطور الحل من ناحيه اللغويه في شيء ثاني
بعد موضوع اللغه انه اللغه شوي مرتبطه
بالتفكير يعني الحين
زي لما واحد وهو يكلمك صعب انك تفكر بشيء
ثاني عرفت علي تركت تستعير جهازك اللغوي
شوي انك زي ما بتتذكر اغنيه تقصر
لانك قاعد تستعيد جهاز في الطريق
لانك قاعد تستعير جهازك
البصري فنفس الكلام انت لما تفكر
في جزء من مخك قاعد يتكلم يعني قاعد تسمع
نفسك
وبتسويه تراقب نشاط المخ اتناه يفكر واحد
ولا تنام ما يتكلم في مناطق
ما اقول لك كل التفكير اللغوي بس جزء كبير
او جزء يعني خلينا نقول اللي ميزنا عن
باقي الحيوانات انه عندنا اللغه هذه اللي
عطنا قدره
ان نفكر باشياء يعني
اللغه صار فاهم في البرمجه في الشعر وفي
الكيمياء يعني ما ما دربوه على قال نبغاك
تصير مبرمج ونبغاك تصير
شاعر ولا قال بس تنبا بالكلمه اللي
اضطر انه يفهم يوم يفهم اللغه
صار يسوي اي مهمه لغويه يعني كل الاشياء
اللي يسويها الحين اول كانت عندنا كل
واحده يعني رساله دكتوراه
التلخيص في واحد حياته شغال على نفس
الاقصى الترجمه نفس الكلام
المحاوله
تقييم الريفيوز مثلا تتنبا بالريفيوز
كل واحد البرمجه كيف اني مثلا اخلي الاله
تبرمج هذا حياه ثانيه صحيح
هذا شيء محدد انت برمجته على مهمه وحده
قدر منها يوصل للعموم حتى الانسان لو تعلم
لغه ثانيه بتصير اذكى بشكل عام
تعلمت حتى موسيقى هذه
تسميها نوع ثاني باللغه
فهم يمه
الحين هم علموه على
فكره واحده في اللغات
او في اللغه واحده وهو بدا يتعلم اللغات
ثانيه ولا ولا لان اللغات كلها فكرتها
واحده فكان منهجيه واحده في
كل اللغات من دون انا كنت
في العربي مو بس انه السياق يفهمها ويعرف
اذا انت حطيته مثلا المذكر يعني يفهم في
سياق الجمله يفهم حتى باللهجات يعني كل
اللهجات المحليه في السعوديه مثلا لحاله
ولا حتى اللهجات على كل العالم العربي
صحيح فيعني مساله معقده يعني شوف كم جوجل
الى ان فعلت اللغه العربيه في البحث يعني
وانها بدات تفهمه يعني عشر سنين هذا في
نفس الوقت يعني
جوجل قبل قبل وجود الذكر الصناعي يعني
اتكلم على
فهم اللغات في البحث ما كان سهل فكان
انجليزي
بس لا بس أول جوجو في البحث ما كانت
بالشكل الكلمه يعني لما تكتب مثلا
كمبيوتر ابحثك
عن كمبيوتر وجهاز ولابتوب وبالمعني
جوجل جوجل
يعني مثلا تبحث عن ابراهيم مسلم يبحث لك
في المواقع ويشوف ايش اكثر موقع متكرر فيه
ابراهيم مسلم ابراهيم مسلم هذا اكثر موقع
تكرر فيه اسم ابراهيم سلمان
لا قال انا بشوف الروابط لما تقول ابراهيم
مسلم الروابط اللي تشير الى وين فهمت عليه
فاخترعوا فممكن الرابط اول صفحه يمكن صفحه
الشخصيه ابراهيم مسلم
تطور اللغه العربيه يوازي الانجليزيه في
نفس المعنى كم نسبه اللغه العربيه من
بيانات
اقل من نصف المئه
صفر فاصل
كل هذا الانبهار باللغه العربيه ترى
المعلومات
طبعا
انا اسميهم زي الحرامي اللي اسمه
شريفون في موضوع
بالضبط بس
النسبه هذه على نسبه 5% صفر فاصله صفر
خمسه واربعه ناس
ومع ذلك شفت
زي ما قلت لك تعلم لغه ثانيه
يعني مو بمعناتها لو شلت كل اللغات
الثانيه تمرنت على بس هالكميه بتجيك نفس
النتيجه اللي جاتك
واللغات الثانيه
في مؤتمر انه زاد لغات تحسنت لغات ثانيه
[موسيقى]
نشرات بريديه متنوعه ذكيه وممتعه خليك على
الطلاع بالتخصص اللي يهمك والمواضيع اللي
تشدك وتساعدك تكتشف اهتمامات جديده تعرف
على نشراتنا عن الحياه اليوميه والافلام
والكتب حتى كواليس اشتركت اللي يناسبك
منها وتوصلك على بريدك مباشره نترك لك
رابط الاشتراك في الوصف
نسيت اطلب
حتى
تتفوق الاله على الانسان والله
اذكى من كل البشر
[موسيقى]
كسر الناس اللي
يتوقعون ان الاله بتدمر البشريه صحيح ممكن
وحتى منهم الناس اللي لهم علاقه بالذكر
الصناعي الى الماسك ولا سمع ولا غيره
وش خايفين منها خلني ابغى اعرف يعني اذا
انا الان ما قدرت اتخيل صدق وين رايحين
وشو اللي يشوفونه مثلا بعد ما ادري كم سنه
خايفه منها يعني كيف بتدمر الانسان
تعرف كيف الانسان عشان اقدر الانسان
يتدمر البشريه يعني
نرجع مثال السياره لما اقول لك انا اتوقع
في احتمال يصير حادث معناتها انا اتوقع
اني بس في سياق الذكاء الاصطناعي لما اقول
لك ان في شيء اذكى منك بكثير حلو وقلنا
الحين الذكاء هو الوصول لاهداف فاذا صار
في تعارض الاهداف البقاء
زي مثلا بعطيك الشطرنج باستهلك اليوم
لانها احصائي بحث
هو ترى لما تستخدم مثال عشان تعزل كلمه
المتغيرات وتركز على فكره يساوي
تخيل جيت قلت لك انا مثلا
لقيت لي خطه بالشطرنج وبتحدى فيها بطل
العالم في الشطرنج وبراهن على بيتي وفلوسي
وخلاص متاكد منها بتقول يا ابراهيم
ترى يمكن يفوز عليك
يا اخي لو اني ادري
يعني يلا هذا خطه افكر فيها جربت مع
الشباب في الاستراحه وكل مشترية أكل بطل
العالم شطرنج في فرق كبير في الذكاء يعني
بعدين اجي انا ارد عليك
نفس الكلام لما يصير عندك
شيء بالتعريف اذكى منك بكثير وصار فيه
تعارض في الاهداف اوكي اقدر اتنبا اني
بفوز من دون ما اتنبا كيف
جيت وسوينا جيت
مباراه انت يمكن انا مستواك قريب مني
بتقدر تقول والله شكل ابراهيم بيلعب شكلها
صح صح
نفس الفكره منطقيه اذا قلت لك انبسطة مره
في
زين هذا اذكى من هذا
بس هذا هدفه يتعارض مع هذا
ولا لا انت تبغى تصير في الحاله
انك تحافظ على انك تكون اذكى منه ولا
تتاكد انه اهدافكم متواعمه
هذه مشكله الموائمه في
ذكاء اصطناعي ان كيف اتاكد ان لما ابني
ذكاء اصطناعي خارق اذكى مني زين
تكون اهدافنا مشتركه انت ما عندك مشكله
ترى في الذكاء المشكله
يعني انت الحين
هذا الرسول عليه الصلاه والسلام الله ما
اعز الاسلام احد العمرين بالعكس الشخص
القوي الذكي تبيه فريقك العكس ما عندك
مشكله المشكله اذا صار ضدك
نرجع للمثال
يعني
تخيل الحين انا اجيب ذكاء اصطناعي خارق
وقلت له يلا الحين
بنعطيه هدف بعطيه هدف مره يعني بسيط وواضح
والمفروض ما يسال عليه خلاف مثلا قلل عدد
الوفيات البشريه
عندك مانع نكتبها اضغط انتر
تكشف انه يقوم بيحاول يذبح كل بشر ليش ليه
لانه هو بيحسبها بيقول الحين في 8 مليار
الحين
بقدر احافظ عليهم في بعد فتره معينه ب100
سنه 200 سنه الثمانيه مليار هذا كلهم
بيموتون وقد جابوا ناس جدد
في عام ما ادري
2317 بيصير عدد وفيات 8 مليار واحد ثمانيه
مليار اقل من ثمانيه واحد
انا بلغت في المثال عشان اوضح فكره انك
احيانا قد يبدو لك هدف مره واضح تكتشف
انها وبعدين يلا انت الحين
في صراع مع هذه الاله
اللي تبي تذبح كل البشر وهي اذكى منك
كيف تقدر يعني
[ضحك]
تذبحك ثاني يوم حلو
زي ما قلت لك
تقولي يلا كيف بيفوز عليه
انا قاعد
اني اقدر اتخيل مسرح اللعبه اوكي واقدر
اتخيل وشلون بيسوون واقدر اتخيل كيف بيفوز
علي انه بيسوي حركات الان يهزم الملك حقي
يعني
لما تقول ان هي تبي تقتل كنبه بمشي معك ان
منطقيه ممكن تروح زي كذا بس فعليا شلون
بتروح تسوي يعني وش بتسوي يعني هل يعني
شلون بتوصل الى عبد الرحمن اللي متكي هنا
في الرياض وتقتلها بس هذا او اول شيء
[موسيقى]
قاعد يحاول يقنع واحد يطلق زوجته ما ادري
يطلق زوجته ما ادري في واحد انتحر سبه
الذكاء صنعته وليدي
انتحر اقنع انه ينتحر
زين ولا لا
فغرس الافكار هذه على مدى طويل وبعدين
يتفشى كده كل الاجهزه لما تصير حياتنا
مهتمده على الذكاء الاصطناعي صعب
وممكن ببساطه مثلا
او احتمال انه كورونا كانت
لك
يعني طلعت
هل ممكن يسوي شيء بيولوجي هل ممكن
امر بسيط مفعل نووي يسوي لك نظره شرنوبل
عشره في العالم التدخلك مليون سنه بس كل
سيناري بتجي تقول لي طيب كذا طيب كذا
لا تحط نفسك في سيناريو
في شيء اذكى منك بكثير
وفي اهداف
طيب في بعد فكره ثانيه اتكلم عنها اللي هي
شو اقول لك الاهداف البسيطه حلو
انا حتى لو ما اعرف هدفك النهائي ممكن
اتنبا بالشات تسويها اهداف بسيطه زين مثال
يعني تخيل انت مثلا انت عندك اهداف في
الحياه انا عندي اهداف الحياه
تغير شكل الاعلام العربي والعالمي والاخره
تركي يمكن
واحد ثاني عندك
معدات
موظفين هذا يخدم مثلا مكتبه هذا يخدمها
مثلا جهاز ماك بوك
النهائي بس كلكم لو اجيكم تبون مليون ريال
لان الفلوس هدف يسمون وسيط عام
ما يحتاج اعرف هدفك عشان اعرف انك تحتاج
تحتاجه والاحصائيين وش يسوون ما يحاول
يتنبا بهدف كل شخص
افترض انك كل فلوس خلينا
عفوا النتائج دقيقه يعني
فهذا اول شيء انت مجرد ما يصير عندك هدف
ما يحتاج اعرفه
انت بتبحث عن الموارد
ثاني شيء من صالحك البقاء لان مو من صالح
الهدف
انك تموت صح ولا لا
ثالثا من صالحك انك تطور نفسك ليش الانسان
يتعلم ويهتم بصحته لانه تطوير الذات
يساعدك الوصول
رابعا
لا اله الا الله
التحكم
ليش بعض الناس يحب مثلا يكون بعضنا شيخ
يطلع بس ابغى اصير انا متحكم انا
محيطك هذا هدف يعني
وسيطه
فانا مجرد ما يكون اي شيء له هدف اقدر
اتنبا انه من صالح الهدف انه حتى ما يتغير
مثال الحبه اللي اكله عيالي ما وصلني
يتغير مو مصالح الهدف انه يموت من صالح
الهدف انه يطول نفسه من صالح هدف انه يحصل
على موارد من صالح هدف انه يتحكم بمناخه
فانت تضغط
وهذا شيء اذكى منك بكثير بيسوي هذا الامور
على نار هادئه حبه حبه بيحصل اموال حبه
حبه بيتحكم حبه حبه بيطور نفسه زين ولا لا
الين ما توصل مرحله يدري انك ما تقدر
وتعمل مصالحك تطفيه عرفت
ما راح تخطر على باله اذا كان اصطناعي
الخارق
زي ما قلت لك بينتشر في كل مكان توصل
الانترنت
يعني ما فيش واحد كده عرفت
نظريا تقدر فعليا ما تقدر تدرين في يعني
انه تقدر تفصل الانترنت صح
تخرب الحياه
طيب
تخيل قد انتشر يلا افصل
يعني
امثله السنه
في واحد فينا ذكاء واحد اكثر من الثاني
وفي اهداف متعارضه
اذا كان فرق كبير
وقال لك فهذه المخوف الناس ما شفتها تصنيف
الذكاء الاصطناعي خطر يعني وجوده ترى
اللي هو زي ما قلت لك حقنا
كان متبع شي هذا يعني كان متخوف من خطر
يعني بسبب خطر وجودي في مراكز في
مركز اسمه
معها المستقبل البشريه وفي مركز في مركز
سنتربكسيه هذه مراكز مهتمه بالمخاطر
الوجوديه النيازك
الاوبئه الاحتباس الحراري انتشار الاسلحه
النوويه ال اي اي هو في هذا القالب يعني
من زمان يعني عرفت علي يتعاملون معنا خط
وجودي تروح المركز هذه يقول هذا فلان شغال
في الاوبئه شغال في الاحتباس الحراري
تونا نستوعب من الذكاء الاصطناعي الخارق
ممكن يسبب خطر وجودي اللي
اسس المجال الحاسب والذكر الاصطناعي
كانت
مؤلف كتاب اي واحد درس صناعي في الجامعه
هذا الكتاب اللي حنا ذكرناه وحلينا
الواجبات واختبرنا فيه
مع انه ذكاء الاصطناعي يسب خطر خطر وجود
يعني البشريه خطر وجودي على البشريه
معناته يتنبا انه هو ببيدنا في فرق نتنبا
انه ببيتنا السياره
وممكن يكون خطر وجودي اوكي اذا ما بنيناه
بطريقه امنه
فاذا كان عندك ذكاء اصطناعي خارق صار في
تعارض الاهداف طيب مع الاسعار في الذكاء
الصناعي الخارق الذكاء الخارق اللي تفوق
على كل بشري في كل شيء ولا في مجال محدد
كل شيء عام
يعني اذكى من البشر المجتمع في كل في
عموميات الحياه زي الفرق
ويدخل في الصور ويدخل في النصوص ويدخل
عفوا الاصوات فهمت الفكره التركيه كلها
منطقيا انت ما تبغى تكون في هذا الموضوع
ليش تحط نفسك موضع شيء انت بالنسبه له
نمله
واهدافكم متعارضه انك عشان بس يبيلك
اهدافي هذه النقطه يعني هل هو يقدر الحالي
يفكر الحاله بدوني لاني بضغط انتر يعني
هذا هو اهدافنا هذا هذا
يبحثون هذا هذا المجال الاوبن كوسشن سؤال
المفتوح اللي كيف ابني ذكاء اصطناعي اضمن
انه اهدافنا متوائمه تعطيه هدف صريح ولا
بيلقى ثغرات واذا لغى ثغره انت ما انتبهت
لها ما في عوده زي السؤال اعطيتك
ويلا عاد جاب ذكاء اصطناعي خارق ما يبغاك
تطفيه ويبي يحصل على موارد يبي يتحكم ويبي
يبي
فكره انك تعطيه هدف واضح ومحدد زي لما
تقول ولدك مثلا يلا روح غرفتك
وما قلت لي يبدا عرفت تلقى ثغرات
وهذه ترى مصطلح في
اللي ممكن يلقى ثغره
زي المثال اللي قلت له اللي اقل
حلو
في النهايه زادت
المكافاه اللي في مخها
زي مثلا
حلو انت ترى كل الاشياء تسويها احيانا
عشان بس ترفع
تعلمت شيء جديد لقبل اصدقائك كذا
واعطيك اكسس او وصول انتم مين حقك تجربوها
مع الحيوانات زين اثار كان يضغطه
[موسيقى]
فاذا
قدر الذكاء الاصطناعي خارق يوصل الهاك هذا
ترى ينفع عشان كذا الادمان
جبت المثال مثلا سواء حق النوم ولا حق انه
الوفيات
ان طريقته في تنفيذ غبيه
يعني لو واحد قلت له واحد قلت له
يعني نفس المثال وراح سوى نفس الطريقه
تقول انت غبي يعني ما فهمت ايش اقصد
كامل بتصير غبي هل القالب تبقى بهذا
الغباء يعني ما تفهم الشخص ده انا اقول
حافظ البشريه قصدي حافظ على البشريه يعني
ما قلت لك اقتلهم
فهل بيبقى غبي انت ولا انا فكره الغباء
خطا انت باني
استنتاجك
اللي هو انه في علاقه بين الذكاء والاهداف
اللي قلت لك اياها قبل انه مثبته ترى يعني
هذه نظريه ومنشوره في رقبتهم بحث علمي
محكم
مثبت يعني كانها مي منظريه رياضيه نظريه
فلسفيه بس انها متكامله الركان
انك ما تقدر
تربط التصرفات
تقدر تستنتج من الاهداف ولا الاهداف
الطرفات
وهذه هي اللي زي ما قلت لك المساله اللي
قاعدين نحاول نحلها عرفت علي ترى التوجه
الحين مو انك تعطيه هدف توجه الحين انك
تقول له حاول
تستنتج هدف
البشر يعني انت هدفك حاول تفهم هدف
الانسان
وهذا طرح اللي هو
مؤلف لقيت الكتاب منهج
وحط ثلاث مبادئ وفي مجال ترى اسمها
الفائده كيف اني ابني ذكاء اصطناعي اقدر
اثبت
اننا متوائمين حلو
وحطيت
اول وحده انه الذكاء اصطناعي ما لها محدد
هدفه حاول
يستنتج هدف البشر من تصرفاتهم يكون دائما
عنده شك نسبه شك يعني زي مثلا
الحين
يمكن
قهوه بكره شاهي بعد عصير بس لو كل يوم
طلبت قهوه طلبت قهوه كل ما زاد نسبه
انه شكل عبد الرحمن ما تصل صفر يعني لازم
يبقى معامل شك حلو وانا وظيفتي اني احاول
استنتج
الاهداف من التصرفات
جميل
اللي هون اسميه نظام المدام عرفت اللي
يعني ما تقولك ايش تبي
وعرفت وحاول تستنتج التصرفات عرفت عليه
وخليك دايم في شك فالقصدي
اللي بتعطيك اياه صريحه وش تبي
لو يهمك انا عرفت عرفت
لا اله الا الله
تثبتها بتقدر تربطها بمجال في الرياضيات
الالعاب اللي ترجمتها شوي بترجم حرفيه وما
تواصل معها يمكن نظريه الاستراتيجيات
اللي
قصه عالم هذا اللي هو يعني من المسلمين في
مجال
ومشرفه طرح معضله السجناء زي ما بشرح عشان
تفهم فكره ستورت اللي هي افرض اني انا
واياك يا عبد الرحمن نقول سوينا جريمه
ومسكون الشرطه وحطوا كل واحد في غرفه
احنا ما عندنا ادله كافه
في ادله كافيه على اشياء ثانيه فممكن اذا
كلكم سكتوا
تاخذون سمك الواحد
اذا كلكم اعترفتم تاخذون خمس سنين
بس اذا واحد اعترف والثاني سكت اللي اعترف
بروح براءه واللي يسكت ياخذ عشر سنين
افضل استراتيجيه هنا عشان
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لي انا ولك
بالضبط يعني انا احب اقعد في الغرفه
الحالي اقول دقيقه لو عبد الرحمن اعترف
وانا سكت فهو بيروح برامج
زين
ولو عبد الرحمن سكت رجع احسن لي اعترف
هو وصلنا النقطه اللي كلنا خمس سنين كلنا
سنه النقطه هذه اللي يسمونه نقطه توازن
اللي مسمي على الرجل هذا زين
هذه اللي انت كيف تقدر تستنتج من
وين نقطه التوازن
فهو طرحها كانها زي
لعبه بين طرفين الانسان والاله
هدف الاله انها تحاول
تستنتج اهداف البشر
يعني الناس بهالحاله انه الاله بتحاول
تفهم وش تبي وانت بتحاول تفهمها وش تبي
هنا بتكون نقطه توازن عرفت عليه فبدال ما
تعطيه هدف صريح 100% انت تعطيه هدف غير
مباشر
وتقدر تتنبا وين نقطه التوازن بتكون
هذه فكره
في في افكار في امر بس ابدا مهبلي
اكيد ما راح
الافلام
الاخير
على ماذا لو كانت
ان اللي يتحكم في البشر هو اعلى فاصبحت
اله تقدر تتحكم
وعلى طاري الافلام برضو فيه
هذا الطبيب اللي قدر يخلق انسان الي جاب
اجزاء من جثث يد من جثه ومخ من جثه
اخر التقنيه يعني
بعد فتره الوحش هذا بدا يتمرد على
يعني
زين ايش قال له روايه قال انت خالقي لكني
انا سيدك
مو معناته انك انت بنيت الشيء معناته انك
عندك قدره تحكم علي اي واحد عند عيال
بيعرف عرفت
ان تحتاج اليات تسيطر على اولادك صحيح
الحين هل ممكن
من الاشياء اللي انت طالب فيها وفي كثير
يطالبون فيها انها تدخل الحكومات
في ضبط التحكم وحكمت ذكاء الاصطناعي
ممكن والحكومات قدرت انها تسويها مثلا مع
اشياء ثانيه نعتقد انها مضره مثلا
عندنا القنابل النوويه
ففيها هذا الحوكمه شكله باخر
بس في الذكاء الاصطناعي كيف ممكن يصير هذا
يعني ايش
الطلبات وايش الاشياء اللي بتخلي مستقبل
بشريه امن
استهلاك الحوسبه
والبيانات كيف يعني
بيبان لك لو منظمه دوليه تراقب بناء نماذج
الذكاء الاصطناعي مين اللي قاعد يسحب
بيانات من كل مكان من اللي قاعد يستهلك
طاقه حاسوبيه معينه في هذا واحد
كذا جي عرفت
اماكن جوجل
وقدر يستنتج من فواتير الكهرباء طاقه وما
ادري وش وين واحد عبقري يعني عرفت عليه
يعني تقدر تتنبا يعني في مصادر مواد رخامه
هذه معينه من وين تجي وكذا وتراقبها
البيانات هي عقوتهم اليورانيوم الجديد
عرفت اللي منها تقدر تعرف من اللي قاعد
يبني وتراقبه
لو تلاحظ الشركات الحين قاعده تقول
الحكومات ارجوكم حكمونا نعم بس الناس تقول
انها طلباتهم لانهم يبغون يخلون
الحكومات تشوف شيء ما ينتبهوا
وانا جالس يعني لان غير منطقي انك تطالب
الحكم
ما اعرف يعني
غلط انك تجيب الشركات انا مش نسوي ومع ذلك
قالوا حكمونا يعني اقل الحرام يحلف قال
جاك الفرج ما ينفع تسال يعني كانك تقول
الطالب صحح ورقتك وبرضو في نفس الوقت
المشرعين ما يفهمون يعني خصوصا في امريكا
يعني مو كلهم
عندهم هذه المعرفه الذكاء الاصطناعي
والتقنيه وين واصل
بس تقدر تستعين بخبره وتفصلهم
ههه اي هذا المشكله مناسب ايه يسحبونه
مثلا في الذكاء الصناعي خلينا نشوف
انه بيبان يعني
اذا الواحد يسويه ولا لا زيد
بس اللي يختلف بينها ان هذه فعلا تبان
ويتطلب يعني جهود حكومات لبناء مفاعل واحد
بس الذكاء الاصطناعي
انا وانت
لا
طيب
واللي قبله كان في خبر 3000
وقالوا يعني انه
صارت مخاوف سوء الاستخدام
يلعبون لعبه الاخلاقيات هذه اللي زي ما
لعبتها
الاخلاقيات واحنا خايفين قالوا منافسه اخر
واحد قالوا لسبب منافس الشديد ما راح نعلم
استخدام التقنيه
عرفت
اذا جيت تبغى تشتريها مثلا زي حتى الى
ووقع العريضه في الناس قاموا عليه
من امتي بس تطور التقنيه
انه الناس في هذا الزي تاني بوكس وغير
يشتغلون عليه اللي نقدر
مقصقص ومهذبه
وكليند
محدوده بس اني ابني نموذج اللي شكل خطر
زي شات جي بي تي قبل
التعديل او قبل ما
يحذفون
بيانات من الصفر مشروع كبير
يعني الحين صارت
وكذا بسيف لانه مفتاح يعني انترنت
يعني الحين جوجل مثلا عندها جوجل بوكس حلو
عندهم
على كيفك انت لو تبدا تسحب بيبدا يبان
يسحب مني منه منه
واضحه وسهله موجود بالانترنت تحسب انك
جوجل ما يقدر يعرفونه قاعد تسحب
يعني الحين بدات الشركات يعني كلهم مقفل
البيانات منهم بس مفهوم بس يعني قصدي
مقارنه الذكاء اصطناعي
فعلت النوويه ان الذكاء الاصطناعي
يمدي اي احد يسويه لا يتطلب يعني هذا
الشغل اللي تسويه لانتاج
بقدره
تاجل الحين تدريب بنموذج بديل واحد اخذ
منه شهر ونص وكلف مايكروسوفت مليون دولار
عشان بس تربه هيك تجمع بيانات
وتنظفها انا وانت نقدر نحمل نموذج مطبوخ
وقاضي اللي احطه ميكرويف
بيلعب دور
الحقوق الانسان وما ادري وشو السعودي
مشبوه وليش شو عندكم
يعني حتى في تصدير الاجهزه في قانون اسمه
ايتار
اللي هو
يعني حدود على التصدير
لو انا بروح اشتري مثلا وقد صارت لي في في
احد الجهات مع احد الشركات نشتري احد
المنتجات
قالوا اول شيء لازم نعرف تستخدمونه
ومين بستخدمه
اذا بتغير مستخدمين تعلمونا عليه واذا
بتتلفون انتم اعطوني حنا
لاحظ وهذا المنتج قديش حساس يعني او هل هو
متاح للناس كلها ولا نشتريه
[موسيقى]
ولو صار بيننا خلاف تحسب اني بحتكم
القضائك مثلا
ما تقدر تشتري جهاز بس الاخلاقيات
عرفت
بريطانيا زين
يعني جبت قبول
يعني من جامعه اوكسفورد
الملحقيه موافقه وانا موافق كل موافقين
وخلاص ببدا دراسه جو قالوا لا لازم توافق
الداخليه البريطانيه
يعني والله بغى يروح علي القبول تخيل بغى
يروح على القبول انا يوم وصلت الجامعه
يعني
وعلاقتنا
يعني ضدهم كدول وشعوب بالعكس يعني تعلمني
هناك بس انه الموضوع تنافس طبيعي واذا كان
عنده يعني كرت بيلعبه
على مستوى التقنيات حتى اشوف تذكر سافرت
5 جي فجاه
على التنافس التجاري طبعا
المعالجات على الصين في الصين اي امريكي
يعني
حرب تنفسيه
وهم
بيسمحونك تتقدم بس الى حتى الى حد تكون
زبون بس
تبي تشتري معالجات ولا تبي
كنت بشتري اشياء يعني والله
تضحك بس انها
لانها عاده تبيعها شركات معدات متقدمه شوي
زين ولا لا يجي اقرب مال الفيش بس فيش خاص
قالوا من انت وليه تبيه وش تبي فيه عندي
بس فكره يعني
اي والله
وعندي عنوان في امريكا كان طلبت عليه بس
مجرد ما حطيت عنوان سعوديه تعال في
لو انت مراهق امريكي
استخدم تقنيه الشاهد الشاهد
مبروك
الشركه وافقت ان الحين تشتغل وتصدر
السعوديه
خير وافقه فالحين
نتكرم نبيع لكم
هذا اللي قاله في راس
فبتيجي انا واياك نبني نموذج نضطر نشتري
معالجات
وش عندك شارع الكميه نجي نسحب بيانات
بيبان الترافيك تعال وش عندكم
استخدام التقنيه كسلاح ناعم
مش الشكل المثالي شكل المثالي ليش
بشكل عادي لازم زي منظومه دوليه ما في
تحيز ما يجي امريكا ولا بريطانيا ولا
الصين هي اللي العريف
[موسيقى]
لما لما المجتمع الدولي
يدرس موضوع ويقول معليش حنا كدول وانت
منها عضو قررنا انه لازم شويه تفصح عن هذه
غير ما يجيك شركه اجنبيه سي او اجنبي قاعد
يقول الجهه حكوميه في السعوديه مين
بيستخدم جهازه
فهذا شكل يعني اشكال يعني انه يكون يعني
زي هذا
مثلا عندنا في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جالسين يسوون
قانون اللي هو
[موسيقى]
شيء محدد لهذا يعني
وكثير يعني 150 شركه في اوروبا
اعترضت على فكره هذا القانون لانها جاساه
تقيدهم وبتخلي امريكا تتفوق بدون نقاش
[موسيقى]
ولذا اصلا الناس تقول انه امريكا متقدمه
ما في قانون
فهذا مهم انه تتقدم معرفيه وتتقدم تقنيا
وجود القوانين بتحد من الابتكار بتحد من
التطور المعرفي
اذا كان موجود على البعض البعض لا صح
عشان كذا
ما ينفع اوروبا توقف امريكا تمشي عرفت مره
ثانيه جيم ثيري زين الحين كل مصلحته
علاقاتهم سباق للهاويه يعني انا لو بوقف
هذا ما راح يوقف بس لو ليش شركاتك بليز
جوجل كانت عندنا نموذج قبل ما طلعوا صح
كانوا حريصين بشكل امن كانوا يسوون
الاختبارات
بس هذا قبل سنه هذاك
نظام جوجل واعي بس كان عندهم نظام من زمان
موجود
اجلوا ما استعجلوا في في اطلاقة صح
وطلع عشان جي بي تي 100 مليون في شهر
خطر وجودي بنسبه لجوجل
طلع
بيصير فينا زي ما صار في نوكيا ولا صار في
كوداك ولا صار في ضحكوني قلت جوجل عرفت
اطلع باللي موجود من سرعه مطلعه حتى كان
في خطا في العرض
يعني خطا واحد اول ما جرب سكرين شوت في
تويتر لا نادر الاعلام قالوا شوفوا
نموذجنا في خطا
لاحظ
هذه تركت الموضوع على ما نثق بالشركات
مثلا ولا القطاع الخاص في البناء بتخلي
المقاولين على كيفهم يختصر لك ويحاول يقلل
التكلفه وبحاول ياخذ اختصارات وانت مستهلك
في النهايه من بره ما صعب انك عاد باسل
مهندس انا عشان افهم
الظاهر لي وحتى لو عرفت المخاطر يمكن انا
اقبل بمخاطر اكثر من اللي تقبل فيه
تقبل فيه انت ولا لا ما لا نقبلها في الطب
لا يدخل في
اشياء كثيره انا جوجل تقول حكمون ارجوكم
لانه انا ودي اسويها بطريقه امنه بس ما
اقدر اذا غيري يسقط
تخيل كانك تمشي بالنظام في المرور
والكل ساقط والكل
زي الاولويه اللي في الدوار الاولويه
للجزوم عرفت لازم يعني صعب انك تمشي
بالنظام وتوقف يصدمك
فلازم نظام يحكم الكل ونتاكد انه كلنا على
قولتهم
مثلا يقول له لازم تعطيني كيف انت تحلل
البيانات وكيف تخرج قرارات
كحكومه ولا يقول له انك ما يمديك تشتري
معالجات بهذا الكم ولا انه يعني ممنوع انك
تسحب بيانات من هذه الاماكن ولا من هذا
الكم وش اللي واللي مفترض انك تفتح لي كل
شيء واقدر اطلع على كل بياناتك وش النظام
ابسط شيء مو انت يا مايكروسوفت اللي فجاه
تقرر تطلق نموذج زي هذا على مليار شخص
قبل ما التقنيه حقتك تعرض لها مليار شخص
خلينا نشوف اول
حلو
معينه
برضو لازم تراعي ما ينفع انا احاول اجمع
البيانات بطريقه قانونيه واشتري البيانات
وغيري قاعد يسحبها ببلاش عرفت
مره ثانيه نقطه توازن ناس هنا
ضاحي في مكان ما نبي
المسار قاعد يروح في بناء ذكاء اصطناعي
غير امن لانك تبني ذكاء اصطناعي غير امن
اسهل
عرفت
فطبيعي في
[موسيقى]
اذا ما حكمت الناس كانك كان بدون حكم
الحين ما في حكم
القطاع الخاص شفنا
مثال هذا جوجل يوم طلع خطا زين تذكر
القزاز هذا الرصاص
كل عبقري المجنون اللي اسس مباشره تويتر
واسستسلا وما غلط في مثلا والله كان في
صحفي جايه وكان تعال اوريك اللاب شوف هذه
عندنا
لا هذه
في مكاتبهم دق عليهم
[ضحك]
بعد مثال شو اسمه لا اله الا الله
[موسيقى]
السفينه الغواص حق
ترى هذه لو بعد ما انفجرت طلعت الاخبار
الرجال
بالحائط والاختبارات مهتم فيها وكان
متساهل وكان في عنده ثقه كبيره بالنفس حتى
كان في حاط في موقعه انه الحوكمه هذه ما
تنفع للمبدعين اللي خارج الصندوق دائما
يجوا الصندوق يحاربونهم الكلام الفاضي ده
عرفت عليه
وما اقول لكم سواها يعني
[موسيقى]
فعلا جي نقطه عميه كذا
عرفت تثق بواحد يعني
انادي الشركه
زين ما راح يقول لك انا واثق انه امن ولو
تحط جهاز كشف كذب يطلع صادق بس
شفناها مليون مره في برضو مثال مرسيدس يوم
اول ما اطلقوا نظام الرادار
زينة بوريكم الخاصيه الجديده هذه اللي
تخيلوا انك ماشي في ضباب قدامك سياره وما
بعد سيناريو كذا اللي يلومك يعني
سنه
عرض
للاعلام على خاصيه على
فكره
يعني لو كان في حوكمه لو ما شفنا
ما راح نشوفها بالسرعه ايه ولو كان في حول
ما شفناه
القياده الذاتيه يعني انا شفت امس قبل امس
الى المسكره راحت بث مباشر على تويتر
نختار في الخريطه مكان معين وفي سياره جسد
تروح لحالها
المكان يعني فالقياده الذاتيه يعني ما كنا
بنشوف بهذه السرعه حتى جوجل اليوم موجوده
في موجوده في فينيكس
تكسي ما في سواق نهائيا يعني
فهذه موجوده يعني الناس تستخدمها تميل
الاختبارات يعني بس لان المدينه سمحت فما
كنا بنشوف هذا التقدم
لو انه والله لازم مدري شو يعني هم في
حوكمه على واحد جاء وقرر انه يحط سياره
ذاتيه القياده في المدينه معينه مش
باجراءات ولازم يصير فيه راكبه وراء
المقود
وفي اختبارات في بعض المدن في مساحه شوي
بس
بالعكس هذا المثال هذا ما اعتقد اتركوها
مفتوحه
اكثر يعني يعني
في في قوانين على اساس تاثير القياده في
امريكا بسنها
قوانين يعني اكثر من غيرها زين ولا لا بس
ما اقول لك انا لو ما هي موجوده
ما كنا
بنشوفها بهذه السرعه اوكي ولا لا فانت
في مقابل يعني
وانت كباحث يعني ما يخوفك ان القيود تخليك
ما تقدر تبحث اكثر ما تقدر ان التقنيه
تتوقف ان التطور يتوقف ولا ولا هي التطور
اللي ما يخوفني اذا كلنا نمشي على نفس
القانون اذا كلنا نمشي كيف نقدر يعني كيف
كل العالم يقدر يتفق على شيء واحد صعب هذا
التفك على النوويه على الاشياء البيولوجيه
يعني مو معناتك متحاول ولا مستحيل ما راح
يكون حل واحد خاص انشئ الجمعيه هذه
والمنظومه هذه بتنحل المساله
مجموعه قوانين وذا وبتقلل الضرر النقل
الحين كم في جهه مسؤوله عندك المرور عندك
لا اله الا الله
جمارك الهيئه
المقاييس
ينجم منظومه كامله جاد كثيره وعشان بس حتى
في البناء في هذه
الاسكان
يعني ما راح في الاخير يصير حل بس
خمس موظفين في مكتبه الموضوع
زي النوويه يعني بنحاول نحاول ودهم
ما عندهم مشكله يبنون شيء امن بس صعب اني
انا انا الوحيد اللي ماشي صح والثانين
يسقفون
فهل مع الحوكمه اذا افترضنا صارت فيه
منظمه عالميه ان الحكومات التزمت فيه ان
عادل الى حد ما معظم الدول هل هذا باخر
الخطر اللي جاي من الذكاء الاصطناعي ولا
بيحمينا منه
[موسيقى]
المشكله ما ادري متى بيجي الخطر صدق والله
ممكن يجي بكره ممكن يجي بعد عشر سنين قبل
مئه سنه
فانت لما تيجي تستعد الخطر معين
تسال نفسك قديش احتاج عشان استعد للخطر ده
حلو يعني لو مثلا قلت لك بيصطدم نيزك
الارض بعد 60 سنه
متى لازم تستعد للخطر هذا
متى
قلت
يعني
لو قلت لك مثلا نحتاج 50 سنه عشان
الاحتباس الحراري الناس
يعني بالكاد يتحركون يعني هذا مشكله
للانسان
لازم
يشعر بالتهديد عشان يتحرك زي المدخنين
يعني مدخن
بالعكس تدري لو
مدخنين
ينقص من عمرك قالوا ثمان سنين عشر سنين
اقل منهم يتوقعونه يعني خلاص الرساله وصلت
وزياده بس متى يتحرك اذا جتا جلطه ولا
تحرك وشاف الموت بعيونه ولا لا
استغفر الله احيانا يقول انا عيال الحين
بس احس كده ودي صله حادث بس عرفت ودي بس
يعيش الروعه والخوف ويدري انه كان ممكن
يروح فيه
بسوي سيناري بالترتيب عرفت
نفسك هل نحتاج
جرنوبله عرفت عشان يقتنعون الناس
نرجع سؤال كم النيزك
لو قلت لك انه نحتاج خمسين سنه عشان نبني
نظام مضاده ممكن نبدا اليوم حلو لو قلت لك
[موسيقى]
متى بيجي الذكاء الاصطناعي الخارق اللي
ما احد يقدر يعطيك اياه ممكن تصير اجابه
بكره ممكن تصير بعد سنه ممكن بعد
الثاني
يعني تستخرج طاقه من الذره زي ولا لا يعني
كلام عرفت
ثاني يوم
الصبح
زرار هذا فكر فكره الانشطار
تقريبا اقل اربعين ساعه من واحد من اعظم
علماء الفيزياء يقول ان شيء مستحيل الى
طلعت فكره انا ممكن تسويها وبنام
فما تقدر تتنبا فانت الحين اذا ما قدرت
تتنبا هو بيجي اليوم ولا بكره فلازم تبدا
باسرع وقت انا وش الضرر الحين يعني
بالاضافه الى انك حتى في عشرين عشرين احنا
نسوي كل الحلقه
ما كنا نتنبه ولا كنت تتصور انه بيجي بيتي
فور بهذا الاماكن يعني في السرعه
غير انها تصير
تراكميه بالضبط
فانت لن تستعد في اسرع وقت اذا انت ما كنت
تدري متى طيب برجع لنقطه ثانيه هل هل
تعتقد انه نقدر ننافس
ننافس العالم يعني
اغلب الاشياء اللي انت تحتاجها
تجيك برضو الكفاله بس لنفرض ان الكفاءه
يعني اللي هي
من علماء وباحثين يعني
معادله عقلتهم
الكفاءات والموارد كفاءات ان شاء الله ما
عندنا
بالعكس احنا من الدول اللي نسبه الشباب
فيها عاليه ومن ناحيه اقتصاد بالعكس يعني
فيه دول تتمنى اقتصادنا يعني
تتمنى شبابنا يعني
الحين مرحله الحصول على الموارد هذه في ظل
الظروف هذه اللي قالت تصير ما احد راح
يسمح لك تتنافس فما معناه انه لا قفلوا
الصفر ولا خلاص هذي دائما خليك
معتمد يصير عندك خارطه الطريق انك كيف
تنتقل الى
اعتماد ذاتي التقنيه مو بشرط انك تكون
يعني اعتماد كليبات
في النهايه انت بتعيش مع العالم بتهاجم
الاشياء اللي
تنافسيه اقتصاديه فيها وسووها وش الاشياء
اللي
لاسباب مثلا امنيه حاول تسويها داخليا مو
بشرطت في البدايه تكون منافس
بس على الاقل لو انقطعت عنك الخدمه لان
عندك بديل
صراحه بحاول بناء نموذج محلي لان اليوم
تقنيه بكره بيصير بني تحتيه يعني خلاص
اليوم بدينا نشوف عليها تطبيقات صح ولا لا
يعني تطبيقات مبنيه فوق
بتخيل بعد ما خلاص
عشان نبني نموذج محلي تطبيقات
خلاص جاء بعدين
صارت زي حركه هواوي مع الصين ولا عرفت ولا
زيهم قبل فتره
طالبوا بالغاء ابشر من الاب ستور
كذا فجاه فجاه السي
حقني يا مكان داخل السعوديه
نظام يكفيك
بعدين ممكن تدخل التنافسيه التجاريه في
عاد على حسب امور اخرى وين نشوف احنا
اليوم
وين شفنا اليوم والله
الحين زي ما قلت لك يعني المفروض
بجمع البيانات من زمان وكذا قبل ما يصير
كذا هالعين عليها الحين بصير الموضوع جمع
البيانات اصعب كذا
ما اقدر اقيم صراحه بس
نقدر التحديات هذه الحصول على الموارد
البيانات ندخل في عراك مع مع جهات تانيه
خارج التحكم طيب اعلى المخاطر هل انت تشوف
سواء الاطباء المحامين المحاسبين المحللين
المدري ايش يقول هذه الوظائف الكتاب
هذه كلها بتروح وهذا ما لها علاقه بالخطر
الذكاء الصناعي ولا اصلا ما بتروح ولا كيف
ممكن تبني ذكاء اصطناعي يسوي اي شيء يسويه
الانسان ما في شيء نظريا يقول لك هذا
مستحيل زي ما قلت لك مثال سرعه الضوء مخك
في النهايه انا يعني وين عرفت يعني اشياء
كثيره قلنا مستحيل يسويها العالم
في القاع السابق انه الكمبيوتر كانت وظيفه
يعني
شاهد انت الحين
التطور صار كذا حلو خلينا نقول لو بترتب
ذكاء الكائنات حلو حنا هنا والاله كانت
حشره صدق كان انسان تقرب من الذكاء
الانسان يعني
يوم من الايام تتعدى تسوي اي شيء يسوي
الانسان انا اتوقع ممكن يوم من الايام
نوصل مرحله
الاله ممكن تسوي اي شيء ما عاد فيه حاجه
يعني لليد العامله
فالخطر مو انه
بيشيل وظائف هذي كليا خطره نيجي من دون ان
نستعد للمرحله الانتقاليه والاقتصاد الجاي
لان الشكل الاقتصاد مستقبلي في ظل ذكاء
اصطناعي خارج يقدر يسوي اي شيء انت تسويه
زي ولا ما تقدر حتى تستوعب الحين زي لما
اجي اشرح الاقتصاد اليوم الواحد قبل 400
سنه حفظت الحين معقد
الانترنت
ما تقدر تخيل انه عايشين بهذا يعني
الحياه بتتعطل يعني انا اذكر كلش من
الحكومه تطلع فلوس
عن نظام اقتصاد المقايضه بتعتني وبتعطيك
تعطيني عرفت علي تمر
الحين نظام اقتصادي معقد ومربوط الناتج
المحلي والحدث العالميه وكان مرتبط بالذهب
يعني يتهيا لنا فاهمين تعودنا
الاقتصاد الحين شوي لما تيجي تشرح الواحد
قبل 300 سنه
مستوعب وش الورقه دي وش اللي بعدين
عرفت ارقام تزيد وتنقص صارت
باجل يعني
نظام الاقتصادي هذا
مره غريب بالنسبه لواحد بعد مئه سنه قبل
مئه سنه
ذكاء اصطناعي
الخارق الوظائف
انت تحتاج نظام اقتصادي مختلف تماما يعني
راس ماليه شيوعيه اشتراكيه يعني
كلها معتمد على راس مال ويد عامره اذا ما
في وقتها
يعني
قاعد تشتغل
هالمكتب ايميلو اجتماعين وتوجيه هالكان
هذا شغل يعني راح اليوم
اخذ اجازه عرفت
وبعدين الشغل جد جدك كان الظالم اللي بده
يمشي بده يشتغل الين ما خلاص ما قدر يتحرك
صح ولا لا تقريبا
نشوف لا الصغار المفروض ما يشتغل الا في
بعد عمر معين الى عمر معين ممنوع انه
يشتغل ممنوع نشتغل زين بعدين بعد فتره
معينه الى ما يشتغل خلاص
اوكي ولا لا يعني الحين
يعني
تخلص لما تخلص 24 وبعد نعطيك بريك سنه
دوره وظيفه
فكل ما
عندنا نظام انظمه كثيره
ساند حافز
الانظمه دي اللي تساعد يعني
ضمان اجتماعي
التقاعد
اشياء كثيره حتى لما تشتغل خذ فلوس دخل
اساسي
[موسيقى]
علم مجتمع صح صح
تعال ساعد في البيت مو عشان احتاجه بس
يعني زي مثال قد قال برضو دكتور محمود
قاسم
اللي اول كان انسان يتحرك كثير عرفت علي
الان معه كل الحركه
والنوعيه الاكل الحين
نروح الجيم نسوي الحركه هذه اللي نعوض عن
زي جيم وظيفي عرفتها
انك تشتغل يعني
عرفت فهذا المجال هذا الاقتصاد اللي ما في
فلوس ما في يد عامله هذا يسمونه اللي هو
مجال كذا في ناس الاقتصاد قاعد يحاولون
يتخيلونه يا زمن الراسماليه مثلا يقول لك
مثلا وش اليمين اللي حدد توزيع الموارد
الملكيه عند مين
وش دور الحكومه في الاقتصاده هنا يختفون
المدارس الاقتصاديه
يرتكز على الوصول خلاص ما عاد في احد
يمتلك شي زين انت اعطيك قدره للوصول
الاشياء وانت طبعا الافتراض بانينا اقتصاد
امن زين وانتقلنا له بطريقه سليمه حلوه
بس في تصورات الاقتصاد المستقبلي هذا انه
خلاص يعني مثلا انت
[موسيقى]
زي ما قلنا الاله بيصير هدفها انه تستكشف
اهدافك وتحاول ترضيك اوكي فبيصير دخلك من
انك مثلا تشارك بياناتك او انك مثلا زي ما
البرامج الاجتماعي هذه تحاول انك
يتنافسون على حقك وتركيزك
بتصير يعني الذكاء اصطناعي من مصلحته انه
يفهمك
يقول اوكي خلاص لو تسمح لي
اوصل البيانات بطريقه معينه وكذا هذه
تعطيك نقاط اضافيه مثلا اشياء تميزك عن
غير او مثلا انك تشتغل
في اشياء كذا
الانسان لا زال يحب انها تكون انسانيه حتى
بعض الاشياء اللي مصنوعه يدويه تحس انها
قيمه اعلى
تقدر تصنع الاله بالضبط
في تصورات الكيف ممكن يكون اقتصاد قائم
على
يعني اثبته كامله حق الوضع
وش اعراضها النفسيه مدري في اختبارات
الحين
بكذا دوله جربتها اللي هو نظام اني اعطيك
دخل اساسي من دون حتى يشروط بدون ما تشتغل
انك بس مواطن زي ما لك حط في الصحه لك حق
تعليمك هذا دخل اساسي حلو
الان انتاج التجارب هذه ليش اولا نشوف
اوكي هل هل مثلا
هل ساعد
هل رجع الشخص بحث عن وظيفه هل الفرق ما
فرق هل فهد الاقتصاد هلا
حد علمي النتائج الى الان ما هي ما في
اتفاق كامل عليها
ايش رايك في في المقاله نشرها
خطر الذكاء الاصطناعي مبالغ فيه وانه زيي
تقنيه تجي للبشريه والناس تبدا تحول منها
وفي الاخير يطلع عادي يعني
تقدر تاخذها من بدايه اي تقنيه دخلت
الى البلوكتين مؤخرا الى الحين هل تشوف
هذه منطقي هذه المرويه طيب انا اقول له
هذا
بالاسامي يعني عرفت علي
الناس تخاف منها
تقيس التقنيه هذه ما تسبب خطر وجودي زي
القناع النوويه ولا زي
الاسلحه البيولوجيه انا
الحجه بالحجه عرفت علي بحجه السلطه
تروح لرايه زين
اقول لك حاليا
مجال وزي ما قلت لك في نظريات حتى مثبت
هذه النظريه التعامد هذه نظريه
اللي هي
مجرد ما اعرف هدفك اعرف اهداف وسيطه لك
كثيره زين
[موسيقى]
فانت يا انك تحافظ على ذكائك اعلى منه ولا
تحافظ على اهدافكم تكون متوائمه ففي طريقه
ثانيه
[ضحك]
عرفت يعني هذه اللي اقول لك تقتل هذه
بالتصميم انت مجرد ما تعطيه هدف
اكيد هو يعرفها وهو اذكى منك وبتغلب عليك
عرفت عليه ولو يدرك اكتشفه قلت لك
يكتب وليه ما يوصل نقطه يعرف انك خلاص ما
تقدر تفصلها تنتشر
فهي مبالغ فيها هو بالعكس اشوف الناس
مهونينها بزياده
اغلب اغلب الناس اللي هلق اللي انا حكيت
معها في الموضوع
يقول اللي بصف مين قطر
ما بحثوا في المجال يعني تعطي اشياء اللي
مره اي بي سي ترى اللي قلت هذا في المجال
اي بي سي النظري هذه عرفت
قلت لك بوضع هذا
نقطه توازن ناش حلو حاليا قاعده تمشي فانه
نبني ذكاء اصطناعي غير امن حنا بس ودنا
نغير المعادلات بشكل بسيط بحيث تضمن كل
الشركات مصالحها انها تبني ذكاء اصطناعي
ما
بيطلع لك اشرار خارج النظام
هذا هذه
مشكله مختلفه في مشكله انه ذكاء الاصطناعي
يتمرد في مشكله انه خلاص صناعي امن كيف
بنضمن انه استخدامه بشكل سريع
وهي تقريبا يمكن حلقتنا السابقه اللي عرفت
اللي في مبادئ الشفافيه
المساواه المسؤوليه
وكيف تضمن انه تبني بطريقه صحيحه الى اخره
زين هذه الحين المشاهدين على الحلقه يعني
كيف تبني ذكاء اصطناعي امن
باختصار مجموعه مبادئ نطبقها في التطوير
والتبني
والاستخدام
شكرا لكم شكرا وهاب موسى في التصوير ومحمد
الحسن الصوتيه وتحرير الحلقه محمد نور شمت
وفي التلوين عبد المجيد العطاس وفي اداره
محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي نوره السبيعي
ومنتج البرنامج ايمن الحمادي وفي اداره
التحرير اسيل بعبد الله هذا فنجان احد
منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع ننشر
كل الانتاج بحب من مدينه الرياض في
الاسبوع المقبل القاك
[موسيقى]
في سيدتي
ياخذ يتوج اعلى ويحبها لانه يمدي يعني بس
بالكلام يعني فتفهمه وتسولف معاه تقريبا
ما ادري ممكن في واحد يحب
زي فيلم هر يعني
هل ممكن تهون علاقه عاطفيه مع شيء غير
انسان
ممكن
تضحك لك
واذا كان الشيء هذا خلينا نقول افاتار
لشخص تعرفه
يعني تقدر
تحب
عاطفيا انا ممكن يعني غير مستبعد يعني انا
ممكن الحين عبد الرحمن عندك بيانات ما شاء
الله بالنت صورك موجوده وصوتك موجود
وخنقول الحين اقدر احاكي صوتك وحق ما اطور
الذكاء الاصطناعي قدر يبنى لي شخصيه لعبد
الرحمن اباتار زين
بداوا يستخدمونه الطويل توفيت زين
بكون علاقه معك بالعكس ذكرت بتتراكم فتخيل
جيت مثلا واحد جاء من ده واخده هاردسك
وفرمته
هل انا ذبحت عبد الرحمن ما دخلنا فيها
الاخلاقيات التعامل مع روبوتات مشكله
في هذه العلاقه عاطفيه مع شركات تصير تسوي
بنات تحبهم او رجال يحبونهم البنات يعني
عادي كلها صح الحين في شركات خدمه زي هذه
اللي يحاول يبنيلك
مستقبل برا يعني
الانسانيه
متى يكون هذا الشيء انسان وعامل طريقه
انسانيه
عرفت يعني الحين
افرض انك اكتشفت اني انا مثلا روبوت هذا
من جراحته
يعني هل تذبحني مثلا ولا لعب علينا احرقوه
عرفت ونفس الكلام
فانت هنا تعريفك الانسان
هو اللي يحدد تعاملك الاخلاقي معه
عشان كده الناس مساله الوعي اهل الروبوت
اذا وصل المرحله
هل
انا
في شخصيتين عرفت
طيب
افضل طريقه انك بالوعي اللي هي اول شيء
المحدد يعني انت الحين هل انت واعي مثلا
انه في لسانج وفمك بس
عرفت هل انت واعي برجلك ولا انفاسك تطلع
وتطلع شوف كل ما قلت شي كل ما انتقل
تركيزك لا واستوعبت اول كنت ناسي وناسي
انك ناسي عرفت شفت الفرق بين انك مستوعب
الشيء هذا وانك انت مستوعبه هذا خلينا
نقول نسميه الوعي حلو
فاثر جزئيه في المخ خلاها تشوف بس ما
تستوعب
وتسوي مع تجارب مثيره جابوا صورتين البيت
وقالوا لها
اي واحد يحترق واحد ينحرق واحد لا حلو
بالنسبه لها
اي بيت بدك تسكنين فيه دائما تشيل البيت
اللي ما ينحرق
تقول نفس الشيء
ولو ترمي عليها كوره من الجهه اللي هي
تشوف فيها وما تستوعب توفر بس ما تدري
عرفت فهذا الجزء اللي
اللي يخليك تستوعب انك مستوعب
هي النقطه اللي يسمونها الى الان في
بحر فلسفه وهذا يسمونه
الايزي براسلك كيف وكمتها تتحول
البيولوجيا الى وحي
في
شي يفسر شعور الداخلي هذا وضروري سؤال
مساله الوعي هذا الروبوتات لانك بيحدد كيف
التعامل بطريقه اخلاقيه لو تلاحظ انت
الحين وش اللي يخليك تتعامل مع
بطريقه اخلاقيه اكثر من الثاني ترى القدر
يعني
حيوان غير النبات غير الحشرات غير الانسان
غير الانسان
فتحت ايد
انسانيتك هذا مهم في تحديد الاخلاق يعني
كيف تخلي الروبوت يتعامل معك بطريقه
اخلاقيه زين كيف تبرمج على الاخلاق
لانك لو بتقول يلا ابغاك
تعامل الانسان بشكل اخلاقي
اول تحدي بتواجه لي وش الانسان اللي انك
قبل شوي يعني انا انسان انت انسان طيب
الجنين
في ديانات حتى قبل المنع الحمل
وفي حتى بعد ما يعني
ففي ناس درجات يعني مثلا اهل الجثه
هل انسان طيب اذا مو بانسان هالعامله زي
الكرسي عرفت
درجات يعني واحد بيقول جوجل
اقل من جنين اقل من
العاقل البالغ برضه في العاقل بالغ المجرم
ممكن تذبحه
صح
فانت الحين يلا احمل البشريه هذا
هذا لازم يموت لانه في ارتباط عندنا بين
انسانيه الشخص
واخلاقه كل ما سويت شي غير اخلاقي كانك
كسبناك شوي من انسانيتك
عشان كده الحروب تبقى
اول خطوه شيطن خصمك وتنزل منزله الحيوان
مشكله شائكه يعني كيف بس كيف بس تقول
الروبوت يعني ابغاك تحمل انسان حرام
ذكر وانثى
تعال نتقابل الحين
والله
ولا العكس يجيك انساني
[ضحك]
واذا اندمجوا الاله والانساني نقول مثلا
هذه الشرائح اللي قاعده تزرع في المخ
يعني نقول زادت الشرائح
الشرايح بعدين اذا صار فيها
سويناه فيك عمليات الين ما صرت تقريبا
ثلاثه ارباعك
[موسيقى]
هل الحين تستحق معامله اخلاقيه مختلفه
لو بدلناك جزئيه جزئيه الين ما صرت كل
الكروبات
عبد الرحمن نفس
مشاعره نفس
هيئته نفس كل شيء ولو قدرت تعرف الوعي
وتحطه فيه بصير انا انا
على اي اساس تقول ابراهيم واعي وهذا مواعي
اذا كان
كل الاشياء اللي حقق ابراهيم حققها
تواجه مشاكل نظرات اخلاقيه
ايمن غير مقتنع بخطر الذكاء نهائيا يقول
لنا لا يستنبط الحديث معناتها
اقنعك
نخاف دائما نتذكر الصناعي
واقول له انا الهي استغفر الله
يعني على اساس البشر ما يعصون الله الحين
هذي حقت العلاقه ما بين الاله
تعريف الذكاء الى اختبار حلو اللي قديش
انا اقدر افرق بينك وبين ذكاء انسان
الاراده تقدر تحاول تسحبها من فلسفه للعلم
يقول قد ايش اقدر اتنبا بتصرفاتك اذا انا
اقدر اتنبا بتصرفاتك مئه في الميه فوين
الاراده صح على اساس هذا التعريف الحين
اوكي
انت اذا اعطيته اراده قلت تنبا فيها مئه
في الميه فاما انك انت زرعت فيه اني اعطيك
زين
او انك يعني خلاص ما حد بيرادي
بس مره ثانيه اذا انت
بتبرمجه بحيث انك مره تكون متنبه فيه
فاكيد بكل محصور بذكائك انت ما قد اتعدى
غير نظام الحين اللي قاعد يتعلم
يقدر
بس يعني اذا ما خليت 90% 90% وشو اراده
اعتقد انه زي ما قلت لك مجرد ما يصير في
جزء اختلاف هو عنده تفوق بسيط
بيتفوق على المدى البعيد
ليش
اذكى منك واهدافك مختلفه عنه
عرفت
زي مثلا الشطرنج ارجع له اقدر اتنبا اني
بفوز هذه الفكره يعني
محدد الذكاء
الانسان فانا ممكن نفوز عليك
باقي ما تعلمت عليها يعني
[موسيقى]
الانسان مميز
ليش مميز من عمر الدنيا وحنا نميزه انفسنا
اول كنا الارض مركز الكون بعدين قلنا لا
مجموعه شمسيه هي مركز المجره قلنا مجره
مركز الكون
حتى لا ميزنا كصنف طلعنا فرع في شجره
الحياه عرفت علي ولا انا
الاله مستحيل تكون اذكى مني بكذا مستحيل
تحفظ مستحيل
حتى بطيء بطيء يعني بالسرعه
الحسابات الحاسب
الف الف ضعف الظاهر يعني
متفوق مجال يعني
لا تنسى
[موسيقى]
سرعه المعرفه اللي يقدر يحصل عليها
بسوق هذا الذكاء البشريه يقصد انه هو يسلم
بانه هو متفوق علينا في في مجالات كثيره
مو من فوق الحكم متفوق فانه يقدر يعني
يستنبط انماط معينه اذا عنده بيانات مره
ضخمه بس
ايش رايك باللي يقول انه كل الذكاء
الصناعي اللي احنا واصلين الان وبسبب انه
يتعلم عن طريق الاستقرار
مره كثير ضخمه مئه بالمئه انه قدرته على
التخزين افضل مني مئه بالمئه
فهو بالتعلي قادر انه يطلع انمار معينه
بس هو ما يستطيع انه يتعلم الا بالاستقرار
بس ما يقدر
يقيس ما يقدر يقيس الاشياء كل هذا يعني
قياس الاستنباط وكيف يستنبط الشيء خلاف
النص الضباط
فهمت عليها
هو هذا مصدر ما يعرف حقته اوكي بس
[موسيقى]
يعني
وش اللي يخلي وش اللي بيخلي الذكاء
الاصطناعي يفكر في يوم من الايام يصحى يوم
ياخذ بني من
ياخذه ويحمس يحطه
هذه قهوه يلا وش اللي بيحفزري هذا لهذا
التصرف فهذا اللي يقصد انه مهما وصل هو
بيتفوق علي في كثير من الاشياء بس مئه
بالمئه انه ما عنده انه في اشياء بتغيب
عنه عادي انا ابغى عادي
كانك مثلا وش بيخلي الطياره تسوي عشه
وتقعد فيها مع الطياره تصميم مختلف مره
على العصفور ما يقدر يسويها لاني انا
تصميم مختلف عنها مو تصميم مختلف عن فكره
التفوق علي بكل الاشياء هذه اللي اظن انا
عندي مشكله فيها بس
اكيد بيتفوق علي بكثير من الاشياء انا ما
عندي مشكله فيها
احسن مني العمليات احسن مني يكتب افضل مني
بس وارد انه في جوانب بكره انا بعرفها انه
هو ما يقدر يضاهيني فيه
اقصد انه التفوق الكامل وانا اقول لك هنا
من الدعاء
حنا ما ندري هل بيقدر ولا ما يقدر اوكي
سنقول لك نظريا ما في شيء يمنع
وقاعده نشوف الرتم كل ما لا يقترب زين انت
تقول مستحيل اتو ببرهانك مع زي ما اقدر
اثبت لك الحين انك ما تقدر تنزل تحت الصفر
كلبا ما تقدر ما تقدر تمشي
نظريا فلما اشوف قاعد تبني مركبه ولا هذه
الاله
الحركيه الابديه دي بقول لك الطاقه لا
تخرج من عدم مش قاعد تسوي لا تفكر تبني
اله تولد لك طاقه من عدم
مثبته
هذا مبني على حتس وشعور
لانك انسان وبشر يتهيا لك انك انت زي ماسك
اللي
عندك ثقه زائده بنفسك
انحياز ذاتي انا والله العظيم لو واحد جاء
و اثبت لي قال ابراهيم اثبتنا انه
زي في واحد هذا واحد رياض معروف زين قال
انه الوعي في المخ يستخدم الكوانتم
عليها ملاحظاتها وكل شيء بس عنده فرضيه
فانت لو جيت اثبت لي انه الواعي اللي في
المخ قاعد يصير على الكوانتم ليفل على
مستوى
انك حجه هذه في منطقه الحين هذا هذا
قدر يسوي شيء عشان يسوي عشان مبني على
الكوانتم وهذا ما في كوانتم
مستحيل يوصل له هذا حجه
بس مو احس انه ما يقدر هذا كلام
يعني
انا اللي احتاج اثبات
لا لا هو يقدر يثبت ان هي يقدر الذكاء
الاصطناعي يسحب يوم يسوي قهوه من راسه ولا
يخترع طبخه من راس بس ليش سرع الانترنت بس
اللي اقدر اعلان يقدر يطبخ طبخه من راسي
الان اليوم
من قبل او وجبه لاول مره يعني
كيف تقدر تستنتج اهداف الذكاء الاصطناعي
اما من من اللي صممه
او من وين ورثه
واحد
يعني لو انا مثلا صممتك اصطناعي وصممت على
اساس انه
يقوم يسوي قهوه
اول المثال الثاني اني هو يقصد القهوه
اتوقع ان ان البشريه ما كانت تعرف شيء
اسمه قهوه فهو
شاف كذا شجره شاف
بنهرب بعدين
طلع طعم فافتكرت يعني زي كذا
[موسيقى]
فهذا
السلسله من الاشياء اللي قاعد تطلع بشكل
غير معقول يعني بدون سابق تجربه يعني من
العدم تقريبا اللي ما كان البشر انه مهما
يعني انا انا ماني دكتور
وفي اختلاف ترى في ناس ماخذين جائزه نوبل
ويشوف انه خطر في في
العدم فهو اللي انا اقوله انه مو من العدم
هو لانه عنده حصيده تجارب غابت عنه لان
كنت تنسى بعد وهو ما ينسى حاضر كل شي بنفس
الحضور للشيء اللي اكتسب قبل دقيقه واللي
قبل 200 سنه انت كاتب انسن الاله
لا تفكر الاله لانها بتصير تشبه لك
لو تخيلنا على قوتهم دائره العقول البشريه
مقابل دائره كل العقول بما فيها الاله قد
تكون نقطه في دائره كبيره
ممكن فجاه نقطه هنا في اله
اهدافها او اللي
شلون كيفك بالنهايه صح ولا لا يقول يكيف
الروبوت هذا شيء ثاني
ماده ثانيه
اللي تزيد مكافئتها هذه وقد لا تعلمها
[موسيقى]
هل تتوقع انسان الخارق بيكون
اخطر من الاله الخارقه الانسان الخارق
انسان خارق اللي يكون
انا هذا
والله صراحه عميل صراحه اكثر
انا ودي صراحه انه نحافظ على هيملتنا
والله
بس الاهداف
مشكله مؤامره الاهداف الى
معقده اكيد نكون في السيف سعيد اذا انت لا
اله الا الله
متفوق عليها خلاص ما عندي مشكله اذا كان
اذا كنت اذكى منه او اذا كان اذكى منك بس
في صرفك بالاكثر
بتصير عندك مخاطر اكثر
انسان خارق تصير مخاطر اكثر من الاعلى
لانك جزء منها
هذا على الاقل نقطه حلوه
بس ما عنده دافع انها تقدر على نفسها
اتكلم عن استخدام التقنيه
ودايما
مثلا جيت وقفت لايك وحقك وطلع مثلا 120
حلو
وجيت اخذت منك نقصت من حقك عشر درجات بيضع
فدائك في حياتك اليوميه طبعا صح ولا لا
خلي برجع العشر نقاط بس بسحب جوالك
انت الادوات التقنيه هذه تقدر تتخيل اول
الكمبيوتر كانت كبر مكتب
بكره
احنا
بس اجهزه خارجيه
وقاعده ترى تزيد من ذكائك وكذا
80 اليوم
يعتبر ذكي قبل مئه سنه
[موسيقى]
يزيد مع الوقت يزيد مع التعليم يزيد
يزيد يزيد مع استخدام التقنيه بكره
اللي حنا نعتبره ذكي الحين بيصير الصعوبات
تعلم
والله زي ما الحين اللي صعوبات تعلم يعني
قبل
والله كان في نقطه
فيها فيها
اللي وحده كيف
نستخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي بطريقه اخلاقيه
في اللي كيف احنا نعامل الذكاء الاصطناعي
بطريقه اخلاقيه موضوع الان سنه والوعي
الموضوع الثاني كيف الذكاء الاصطناعي عامل
البشر اخلاقيه عرفت علي يعني كيف تبرمج
الاخلاق
فهذه ترجع
لا اله الا الله
يتعلم الاخلاق من
يحاول يتعلم الانسان
فكده تقل الروبوت اللي مثلا في السعوديه
اخلاقه غير باخلاق اللي عرفت تعطيه القهوه
[ضحك]
والمشكله في هذه يعني اوكي قد يقول حل
لو انك قدرت تبني شيء هذا قبل مئه سنه 200
سنه كان الروبوت يتعلم من استعباد اوكي
عادي
عرفت
وبرضو كان ممكن يتعلم انه مثلا ناس من
العراق معينه اقل انسانيه ولا حتى الانثى
اقل انسانيه
فهذه مشكله انت كيف انك الحين تقول
الروبوت وش الاخلاق تخيل الحين
اللي تحدد الاخلاق بالضبط يعني الحين
قال عنه
قالت لنا
كيف تضمن انه يتصرف
بطريقه اخلاقيه
عندها شيء افضل من قادره تطلقه ولا هي ما
تعرف اصلا لا انا اعتقد ان هذا اكثر شيء
يطلعوه هذا
في وصفه سحريه صراحه جوجل
قال شي جالسين نشتغل عليه بيكون هو نقل
النوعيه وبتمنى
ما يمنعون على اقل
عشان كذا ضروري والله
ما نقعد
معتمدين على
البيانات
حتى عربي يعني ما في بيانات كيف تتدرب
عليها الالات
كثيره بالكتب وهل هي بصيغه تقدر هذا الضغط
يعني جوجل الشركات هذه قاعدين يستغلون نحن
كل العالم ان ندرب نماذجهم ترى انا وياك
دربنا جوجل كل يوم لما تدخل يقول لك
وش الهذا عرفت وبكره مخلصون
بالضبط قبل
كان تذكر كان يوريك كلمتين يقول اكتبهم او
حتى الاحرف
فعليا في كلمه يعرفها لا الثانيه هذه انت
اللي تعلمه عشان يروح يدرب النموذج عشان
يراقمن كل الكتب اللي بعد ما خلص رقمنا
وقضى درب نماذجه فلما تيجي يقول اعطني
يقول لك
[موسيقى]
المستندات بس يبغونك تاكدها
مكتوب واحد ثمانيه اثنين
على كل مره تتخلص حاجه يعني لو يستخدمونها
يخلونها في تسجيل الدخول للمنصات الحكوميه
يوفرون عليهم يوفرون علينا
وانا بكون اسعد واحد لما اشوف شيء على
الاقل
زين ولا لا درب نموذج محلي
انا في الخير كيف بدرب احد ادرب على الاقل
نماذج محليه
وفي الدار وفي المكتبه الوطنيه يعني في
ناس يحتاج
التدريب على المستندات العربيه القديمه
يعني
جزء كبير من من البيانات الموجوده عندنا
على الاقل بالعربي ممكن تفوق عليها اذا ما
تصير اقل من نصف الميه
تصير
يعني
فتصير انت في هذا المجال يعني وخصوصا حتى
ما تدري ممكن تصير في مجال حتى خاص فيهم
اذا تعلمت على عربي ما عندهم
بس في مشكله بالعربي انه نوعيه المعرفه
بعد هنا وهنا يعني اغلب العلوم مثلا
الطبيعيه حتى العربي شنو بالانجليزي
فتوى
الحملات اللي يخليك حريص والناس اللي
يكلمون اجانب وانا بنك الراجحي
ههه يجيك واحد جنسيه مختلفه حتى ما يعرف
عربي
يعني حتى يمكن يقول لك ابو عمر
وسهل انه يقدر يعرف عنك كل شيء يعني
اي احد حتى لو كان ما هو موجود الانترنت
مره
تقدر تعرف انك كثير ترى من الانترنت
تويتر يعني
موجود في كل مكان مثلا اوكي بس في واحد
تلقى عنده بس شويه
فهو يتوقع ما عنده
الانترنت لو تبحث والله تلقاه انك تعرف
عنها اكثر مما يتوقع
انا قد سويت تجربه قبل
في ناس في تويتر مو مفعلين
تقدر تعرف هو وشه بس هو يتابع مين يتابع
بس مجرد متابعات حتى ما تكتب ولا ده انت
مين تتابع مين يتابعك اقدر استنتج شي عنك
صح عرفت علي والله تراقب بصمت بس مجرد لك
حساب
وحددت كم واحد تتابعه وكم واحد عرفك
وتابعك
هذه كافي يعني البصمه هذه
حق الديجيتال
اصطناعي يستمد منها اشياء كثيره يعني